and celebrating in the baby no baby my
skirt is ridiculous
Kelly was brilliant like everybody just
went to another level but he was kind of
like hangover a med for black girls no
it was in a lane of its own obviously
there's some edibles and there's some
actual drugs involved what did you guys
do to prepare for the I have actually
never done so I literally was like okay
like okay so what okay what's going on
and you know you do you do research that
like right actual research online
research and then like you saw so like
other actors me like okay subside and
then you know the director dude there's
kind of like you're just kind of Spacey
promise you don't be mad I took animal
you couldn't wait a little high she's
not so good she's not sober so how did
you prepare for these episodes were
actual edibles
nothing no no one of the harder things
to do because I've played roles before
with like you're drunk or whatever and
the goal is for anyone that is
intoxicated is to try to appear like
they're not and so it's the actors you
know directive to sort of present
someone who's like reaching for sobriety
through like through a haze and her
direction especially like what I'm
looking out of the window and my edible
kicks in was just like you're starting
to see things and you're not sure if
they're real and so she's giving me all
of these directions not even having
anything to do the lines that I have to
communicate but just like the feeling of
reaching for that kind of like sobriety
yeah you're very sick
yeah haze of drugs so it was so fun and
it was fun just to like go kind of crazy
with a bunch of my friends on set take
me through the scene where you get tased
and you you pee on screen right right so
we shot not at Coachella properly shot
in the valley
we're surprisingly temperatures in the
desert drop very low and so it was very
very freezing and we're addressed as if
it's like a summer festival and it's hot
so it was very very cold to shoot and
then mind you for that specific moment
I'm running and diving face-first into a
fall mat multiple times I'm so happy
that Matt was mine oh but I had to do it
so many times I remember going to the
director of this episode Millicent is
incredible pulling up to her before we
started that sequence and I asked her as
just like woman-to-woman friend a friend
how many times am I gonna have to do
this and she was just like you know what
I'm gonna get be straight with you
probably like you know five maybe eight
I was like okay and then that wasn't the
worst of it it was rolling around in the
grass with wet pants and like 20 degree
weather but it was like four o'clock in
the morning and everyone was just like
cheering me on it so I felt super
supported it's a good care of me and I
was standing in front of my co-workers
with wet paint oh well you know what it
was such a good episode I feel like it
was worth it
yes it was probably one of the hardest
ever supposed to shoot free day like
legitimately like that scene when Kenny
gets tased I think was probably our last
night seat tempers it was just like you
got to get a shot we got one leg and
we're running against time cuz like at
five o'clock the Sun comes up and we're
shooting night so like we can't shoot at
6 a.m. because it's daytime it was a lot
yeah we had the fire pit going just
actors gone mad you guys got to get an
Emmy for that one well god bless oh your
mouth got theirs aim they're gonna hold
him now voting now Miley's Gary could be
sitting there since Teddy thanks next
year bring Teddy as your date
[Music]